in the last video we already got an
overview that if you give me a stock
price and an exercise price and a
risk-free interest rate and a time to
expiration and the volatility or the
standard deviation of the log returns if
you give me these six things so if you
give me these things six things I can
put these into the black Scholes formula
I can put these into the black the black
Scholes formula so black Scholes formula
and I will output and I will output for
you the appropriate price for this
European call option for this European
call option so it sounds all very
straightforward and some of this is
straightforward the stock price is easy
to look up the exercise price well
that's part of the contract you know
that the risk-free interest rate there
are good proxies for it money market
funds there's there's there's government
debt things like that so that's pretty
easy to figure out or at least
approximate the the time to expiration
well you know that you know what today's
date is you know when this thing is
going to expire so that's pretty
straightforward
but now let's think a little bit about
volatility so how do you actually
measure the standard deviation of log
returns now one of the assumptions that
about black Scholes formula is that this
is a constant thing this is just some
intrinsic property of this security well
the only way that you can at least
attempt to estimate it is by looking at
the history of the standard deviation of
log returns so the way that people would
normally do it as well they'll say okay
what has what has historically been the
standard deviation of log returns over
some time period where that security has
not changed in some dramatic way and
then use that as the input and then they
would come up with some price well
that's all interesting but it's very
important to know that this is an
estimate this right over here is an
estimate there's no way of us actually
knowing the actual intrinsic and it's
even up for grabs whether there is
whether you can even assume that there's
some constant intrinsic property
as this volatility that's going to be
constant over the life of this option so
this is just an estimate it's important
to know that but what is interesting is
that these things are being traded these
call options are being traded all of the
time and so you could actually look up
the price of this call option you could
look up a call option with this struck
this stock price this exercise price you
know what these two things are and you
could say hey look this traded for three
dollars just now so you actually can
figure out what this is which raises
another very very interesting question
if you know exactly what this is because
you know what or you know what the
market is pricing this at so let me
write this so you know what the market
believes this price should be so the
market believe market belief and it's
based on their actual transaction so
it's based on transaction so this is
what the market is saying the correct
price is so you can figure that out you
can just look that up you can figure out
all these other stuff can you then take
this output plus all of these to work
backwards through black Scholes to
figure out what the market is guessing
about this or what the market is
estimating about that and the answer is
yes and this is where this whole this
whole idea about when people talk about
what is the volatility in the market or
even where is where our current
volatility rates or what does the market
expect volatility to be well how do we
know what the market expects volatility
to be well we can look at what markets
are trading options at and we could look
at all of this other information that
would be inputted into black Scholes
equation and we can say hey look based
on the fact that the market is paying
five dollars for this option and all of
these other variables they must assume
that the standard deviation of log
returns for this security is now this
now let's say that things get really
scary the market becomes a lot Dicer and
choppier well then people are going to
pay more for this option it's going to
drive the implied volatility up so when
you hear people talk about implied
volatility or implied Volland or even
people who will actually trade on
implied volatility so implied volatility
this is what they're talking about
they're saying look options are trading
all the time can we use that price the
market belief
what those prices should be and then
work backwards through black-scholes to
figure out because we know these are all
facts we can look these things up but
based on what the market is trading
these options at can we figure out what
the what the implied volatility with the
implied market belief about volatility
for that security is and then we could
actually aggregated across many many
securities and come up with an implied
volatility for given markets at a time
so it's a very very very interesting
idea but in some levels is kind of a
kind of a basic one you just working
backwards through black Scholes